alright guys we were here with Arjun
we've got a lot to talk about I think
you are one of the realest people and
one of the people who are not afraid to
say what you think and call out the
projects that are frankly unworthy of
existing that's almost all of them how
are you I am doing well man I'm happy to
be here is a muggy day in New York City
yeah for sure alright so for those
people that don't know let's just go
through real quick your background and
then we can can jump into a whole bunch
of him stuff
sure I will kind of start with my birth
only because it's a somewhat relevant
was born in India we emigrated to the
u.s. when I was about six years old so
first generation immigrants was pushed
into the you know lawyer doctor engineer
type mold
my parents are conservative gold bugs
actually we had a rich gold culture
growing up and still do and so I grew up
went to school in Boston was trained as
an engineer and that's when I first
found Bitcoin was in 2012-2013 at sort
of the heyday of the Silk Road you know
that first run up in price that was
really exciting to watch and my politics
were already sort of aligned in that in
that direction in that sort of
libertarian anarcho-capitalists mold and
that was the first time I'd really had
exposure to a wide group of people in
that lens so you know price action dies
I sort of lost interest along with that
you know was just who's building
anything what's going on it wasn't until
a couple of years later that I you know
saw the what was happening in the
community again and started working on
and kind of focusing on Bitcoin
full-time in 2016 and and first thing
that I was exploring is the market
microstructure itself was looking at
where were people you know trading
Bitcoin what
people using the trade Bitcoin the
markets you know still are very
inefficient but was you know far more
inefficient back then exchange arbitrage
was a very big thing the spreads on the
exchanges were very wide there wasn't
really any you know there wasn't a lot
of algorithmic execution the volume was
tiny and so that was my first sort of
area of focus and so subsequently over
the next year and a half and kind of
with all the run-up in 2017 I spent a
lot of my time helping people figure out
how to navigate the microstructure and
how to actually trade you know these
markets and where there are
opportunities to make money and you know
there are all sorts of questions there
you know not only all the things that I
described but figuring out what the
right ways to custody assets and so in
that's sort of foregoing altogether to
the question of you know what do I buy
and so work with a few large traditional
hedge funds you know helping them sort
of evangelizing Bitcoin helping them
explore the space and have since for the
last year spent most of my time
investing and trading my own money with
you know a couple of outside investors
and I'm in the process of
institutionalizing that further which is
really exciting